hey Battle Damage its market odd for
barely political we'd love to see you
guys battle test a Microsoft zoos with
an ancient rune what is a rune
it's like a ten commandments type of
stone but in like from the time of The
Hobbit
released in 2006 the microsoft zune was
the competitor to the already
well-established iPod thus it was doomed
to fail battle damage runs three tests
dropped from a normal height drop from
really high and finally a test of
extreme limits
we're gonna go medieval on this soon and
all this mp3 mayhem will be captured on
our custom-built spinning a slow-motion
camera rig first test of the zoom this
thing seems pretty sturdy so I'm really
not expecting too much but we'll find
out roll action oh my god right away
it's falling apart
I get splitting inside like it still
works so kind of bad for the zoom
lessons actually filled with Nickelback
we must destroy it roll action
oh it doesn't turn on I think it's
broken
but it looks pristine Eric where did you
find this rune uh it was just like in
this dude's garage it's pretty heavy
roll action
that's why the cards armored house the
Zune
it looks broken the camera is not broken
that is also very important Wow
like it's like a beautiful seashell it
still works just kidding huh in the
battle versus ruin and Xun finally I
don't think there's even ever had a
chance to begin with really in any of
these tests or the marketplace remembers
owners that you can request but we've
battled test next I leave me comment
down below with hashtag battle damage
thanks to barely political for
requesting this week's episode check out
their channel over here and we'll see
you next week thanks guys